ouali
dure journée shehu des morts
c'est une blague hilarant à
tu as les compétences requises on
aimerait que tu rejoins à l'air et pillé
puis de la brigade fantôme si tu
préfères j'ai pas besoin de te faire un
dessin la mission c'est de capturer les
crevures les mauvais esprits qui ont
échappé au jugement
son nouveau coéquipier ou l'avoir mérité
en scène nous on est les meilleurs
justicier vivant ou mort
il ya par les esprits qui se planquent
parmi les vivants
bon sang je fais comment pour coller une
balle entre les yeux
encore une chose la punit la même tête
il a même voir avant est ce qu'elle est
sérieux un vieux chinois et toi
je peux pas lutter
j'ai près comme l'ennemi qui pend soir
ministère de la santé on vous soupçonne
est mort en réalité résident tu peux
lamballe et delhaize non moi je
m'approche pas de ça le christ ma part
à
tu remarqueras condat la peau du j'ai
encore super mal j'avais si les morts
prennent le pouvoir s'en est fini des
vivants
ils ont pas choisi le bon endroit pour
la bayard c'est le monde des vivants et
la ratp qui entend bien défendre
photo sort bien
si c'est la fin du monde
c'est marrant non te crise peut pas